the only way that we're going to address
the current deadlock in climate
negotiations that's taking place right
now the reason why cop the last cop
didn't succeed and the next cop won't be
a guaranteed success unless we take
action is because there's a 16 billion
dollar funding Gap that the world's
wealthiest Nations promise to the
poorest Nations but they haven't
delivered on that creates a trust
deficit
if you don't have trust you don't make
progress and so over the next two days
we have the right people in the room
with the most extraordinary heads of
state Business Leaders artist leaders
Foundation leaders who can all come
together with a movement of Global
Citizens to create loss in change and
that's what's going to make the next two
days last yeah and I know how much
action means to you
concerts and we've all been the lineup
is always extraordinary it's always
people you want to see Harry Styles I
love me some Harry is has been it has
been a global citizen Beyonce you name
the names they've all been there and but
even to go to the concert to you you
always make it clear you have to do
something you can't just say oh I love
so and so I want to go you've got to do
something to gain entry into the room
Madam president you are a co-chair along
with you we heard him talk about action
we heard him talk about accountability
what can you do to make sure that there
is accountability because anybody can
say I want to donate I want to do but
how do we hold people accountable what's
the best way to do that accountability
and delivery
accountability and delivery I think to
deliver on what you have promised I
think this is the Hallmark of
democracies because democracies live and
thrive on trust that people trust that
um the the promises and the actions that
are promised are really delivered
and therefore I think it is so important
that's also the difference between
democracy and autocracy because we are
accountable thanks God to a free press
to Global citizen to a vibrant civil
society and of course through the checks
and balances that are out there in the
political field and that's what I am so
amazed about what Global citizen is
concerned because we met at the
beginning of the pandemic and you came
and you said let's organize let's rally
the world and let's organize a pledging
for vaccines to fight the pandemic and
it was at that time 16 billion that we
raised in one evening but what was
important Global Citizens then tracked
each and every single dollar and Euro
that they were not only pledged at that
evening but they were really paid into
the system and that they were delivered
and the second time that we've been
working together was on Ukraine Russia
horrible war in Ukraine and it was you
who said let's again rally the world and
raise money for the Ukrainian refugees
and it were 8 billion euros that you
raised for Ukrainian refugees
and here I was so amazed because you
could you could just feel that people
understood that the ukrainians are not
only fighting for their independent
there in the integrity and of their
territory and their sovereignty but that
they are
fighting for our all of us what the
respect for the international law is
concerned what the respect for the U.N
Charter is concerned and therefore it is
so important that we all support Ukraine
for as long as it takes and again
accountability and delivery to deliver
on the subjects that you have pledged on
or where you have promised things this
is the essence of democracy and to fight
for democracy this is the most noble
task that we can fulfill
you know it's a thing he
you were really from the school if you
don't ask you don't get and you have
never ever shied away from asking both
of you said you squared I can say that
about the both of you Sabrina the motto
is where ideas become impact and I know
you've worked really closely with global
citizen um campaigns connected to food
and hunger and the climate crisis you
know we're not all just sitting up here
looking pretty we really want to make a
difference and we know that these
conversations and these panels and you
get this message out makes a difference
so what have you seen since you started
working with global citizen I think
finally especially when it comes to
climate you know back in the day
people's eyes would glaze over and then
the more examples you give and the more
educated you become you realize Houston
we have a problem
I think that's absolutely right I think
we aren't just here you know just on a
soapbox lending a nice outfit like girls
because you do look it's like looking
pretty
I'll take it
um but what I've learned through the
years with the global Citizen and
actually I met Global citizen doing a
field visit I don't know if you remember
who Mick was there with the
international fund for Agricultural
Development who I am now un Goodwill
Ambassador for and proudly for and they
were in the trenches doing the work
um and it took me a moment to realize
because in my mind at that time you know
Sierra Leone had just come out of the
Ebola pandemic which is where we were
Global citizen kneefad were there
picking up the pieces not knowing
ironically we were about to go into a
global pandemic if somebody had told me
that back then I mean I I don't know
what I would have thought but it's it's
so much more than what happens when
you're in those field visits it's the
follow-up it's the ask like Gail said
and Hugh is not shy to ask none of the
global citizen team are but it really is
that accountability to leaders two
Summits that we go to to the panels that
we are having what is the follow up
behind those panels and I've seen and
I'm so thankful to say have been a part
of firsthand some of those commitments
that have been made you know and there's
been a few along the way and some really
important ones and some I'm really proud
of Canada my own home country stepped up
when the pandemic was happening to help
support a rural stimulus facility when
countries were suffering at the most
because let's be honest like Gail said
people roll their eyes when we're
talking about climate but climate is
such um it's so much bigger than
something that's happening when we get
to one degree or whatever people talk
about it's happening to rural people now
people are waking up not knowing what
the weather is going to be tomorrow
having failed crops I mean these are
real life disasters real life situations
they're on the doorsteps of so many and
it's picking up the pieces and and
finding Solutions in real time that help
people that are going through these
issues in real time climate has exactly
everything to do with gender I mean
women make up the majority of the
informal markets their majority of the
rural populations that we are supporting
climate has to do so much with education
how are you sending your children to
school if you're worried about what
you're going to eat tomorrow it's so
much a bigger conversation than I
initially thought and it's easy to roll
our eyes because it seems like something
that's coming 10 15 years down the road
but the work that we do now helps
support the people who have been
forgotten along the way and those are
people in rural communities who are
suffering through climate change today
not tomorrow so I'm so thankful for the
work that we've done together and the
commitments that we've made and it
really is it's a blessing to be a part
of but the work is important in the
follow-up and the follow-up is something
I think that you've done a really good
job highly yes I mean Sabrina would if
you don't have the planet what do you
have you know and I think people really
need to understand how dire this is do
you have something do you have just a
little climate nugget I'll uh I call it
for lack of a better word that the first
time you heard this statistic or you
heard this philosophy you said oh
we better pay it was did you ever have a
holy moment about something about
climate that sort of Jarred you into
reality there's so many holy s moments
um but to be honest hearing that you
know the people who we support through
efad who are rural people around the
world in the agricultural sector feed a
third
of the world's Planet
one-third that how are we forgetting
about people who feed a third of our
planet and how are they going to do that
if we don't help support them fight
climate change and protect them when
Nature is literally knocking on their
door and
it was astonishing to me the lack of
funding the lack of awareness and
because these people look like me and
you Gail these are black and brown
people around the world rural people who
have not had an opportunity to express
the pain and you know when we do these
visits and and I get an opportunity to
meet some of these people I just think
oh gosh like these are the voices we
should be championing and Global citizen
if anything has done that has had an
amazing way of highlighting voices that
have not been heard who don't make news
segments
um and and that's something that I'm
really proud of yes yes yes Hugh Jackman
I I can't stress enough
um the impact that night in your your
apartment that day listening to Hugh
Evans speak and I know that since then
you've been involved from the very very
beginning and you've
and you've really encouraged other
people to get involved I would imagine
that Hugh calls you at all hours of the
day and night back in the day was there
ever a time when your caller ID said
Hugh Evans and you said not here
but that you didn't pick up the phone
because you're thinking oh Hugh Evans is
calling again
and I'm only I'm only kidding about he
was sleeping on my couch
that's true is that true yeah so there
was no getting away from him
just coming up I've got a meeting and
I'm like you it's been eight days
I I didn't realize we haven't told that
story before but that is true I have
another very important statistic because
I was there not very long ago in Turks
and Caicos at Hugh Evans 40th birthday
so he's no longer a child I just want to
be very clear yes this baby face is
actually a grown-up yeah don't be fooled
by the baby face um
Relentless go ahead he was what he's
Relentless he really is but Relentless
and way yes sometimes people are
Relentless and it's extremely annoying
where they're capital A this is not what
this man does and I can't stress that
enough I encourage all of you to figure
out a way to have a conversation with
him if you haven't already but Hugh
Jackman since you've been here from the
very start what changes and results have
you seen over the years oh so many
changes I mean the
it was 2008 when we first met and I was
so impressed by Hugh as as a man as a
young man his vision he was clear he was
a disrupter but before people even
thought about disruptors right was that
yes but will it sustain and will there
be trust built as you said Madam
president and that is what has been so
extraordinary I think by Hughes
leadership and the entire team of global
Citizen and now here we are uh 10 10
concerts now in Central Park there's
been 33 million actions taken by Global
Citizens there's been 43 billion dollars
raised uh because of those actions and
1.3 billion lives affected that's a lot
from one organization and this started
as an idea 14 15 years ago but what has
been extraordinary is how it's just
grown year in year out and we saw
incredible work as you said with Ukraine
with covert we continue to see great
work and I know it's going to keep
growing because this is a movement it's
like it started as a very bright light I
was like this is an amazing idea it is
now a wildfire and it is just scorching
through and it's really at a Tipping
Point now where I feel it could become
really one of the major forces for Real
Change
it did it started out as a little bright
light and now it is a wildfire and can I
say this guys none of us want to get
burned Sabrina what specific actions do
you think that citizens and government
leaders can address can take to address
the root of food insecurity
no and just to the point again that he
was making about how Global hunger and
climate are an Inseparable conversation
now it's for me it's adaptation
adaptation adaptation it's about
protecting and creating ways for Rural
people to protect themselves against the
effects of climate change
um and you know countries really are now
I think after many of bilat with you and
Mick as starting to understand that
long-term thinking is what we need to
switch to you know there's a lot of
short-term Solutions when you see a
famine these things are important Aid is
important but what are we doing to keep
these uh these instances from happening
again for instance you know I'm I'm
Somali and I don't know if you're aware
what's happening in Somalia right now
but there is another famine another
famine this it doesn't have to be this
way I mean we need to set in stone
measures to build resilience for Rural
people so that when these things do
happen we're not hearing the f word
again and again I've heard it my whole
life now and I'm sick of it so just to
be able to you know pick up with
governments and you know actually even
Germany stepped up and cleared arrears
for Somalia when it came to efat so that
we could unlock 30 million uh in new
funding to be able to to spend towards
adaptation I just it's it's one percent
of the funding at the moment and it
needs to be at least 50 when you're
talking adaptation and mitigation
um so I'm looking forward to picking up
on those conversations and then on a
individual level and one of the reasons
I think panels like this are so
important it's about listening learning
and using your voice because everybody
in this room now has learned something
from one of the panelists up here that
they can now share or help spread the
information for my mom always said to me
you know your voice is the most
important thing you have because even if
you can speak to one person you are
influencing some kind of change and it
is so important to remember that Global
citizen provides everything you need to
be able to use your voice in a way that
actually matters and that's all they're
asking if you don't have a dollar to
your name your voice is worth more
um so I think it's so important to
remember that I also think that for
those people who have the power of the
microphone please use it for good
because there will come a time when you
will no longer have the microphone and
could we just say congratulations and
happy anniversary to Sabrina she and her
lovely husband Idris Elba have been just
celebrated an anniversary here in New
York City and now she's with you happy
anniversary happy anniversity thank you
um you Jackman you said that
sustainability is something I've seen
this in action with you that you're
you've been very passionate about your
whole life so can you share with the
audience how you took that passion that
you have and you turned it into to
action I went to Ethiopia 2009 as an
ambassador for World Vision and we did
some work with fair trade Farmers I met
a guy called ducali he had five children
a sixth on the way and I spent a day
working with him in his farm and he
didn't speak a word of English and
somehow by the end we became friends and
thank you for a second working with
somebody and their farm and they don't
speak English and you don't speak their
language how did you communicate that
way he just pointed dude gave me the
shovel do this okay I just followed got
it got it and it was the hottest work
I've ever done I'm an actor after all
this is I'm like golly I can do this for
like 30 minutes that's it
um but I made a promise to him that I
would do whatever I could to help
farmers like him fair trade farmers and
so uh in New York City here me and my
partner started a non-for-profit Cafe
Laughing Man coffee which is down on
Dwayne Street if you want to go and get
it we give our profits back to the
farmers we buy from like to Carly did
you say the name of that again please
you laughing or laughing laughing man
Cafe okay there's two of them a third on
the way but it's it was just a small way
for us to to connect the dots and to how
I could use my platform hopefully to to
make a difference to the people we met
you know because I think as Sabrina was
saying there's so many small farmers
like ducali who are on the edge One Bad
season it's all over you know the
instability and the insecurity they live
with is just unimaginable to most of us
here and a little bit of help from us
goes such a massive massive way and I
always go back my dad used to remind me
you know what Mandela always said it's
poverty is not natural it's not a normal
state of being it may be around but it
is human made and it can be human
corrected as well it's up to all of us
there's more than enough resources for
everyone on this planet we just have to
find creative ways to share them yes
poverty is not natural I love that plan
you I know who Evans you've never backed
down from a challenge and so I want to
end with Madam president but before we
do that what's the first step you think
we can all take to make an impact
well I think firstly it's important to
realize that in this room are some
absolutely Extraordinary People I'm
going to single a few people out
Michelle Anthony and Kelly Curtis at the
front are two of the most important
leaders in the music industry in the
United States prime minister Ernest
Solberg of Norway who ran the entire
Norwegian economy for the last 10 years
and has now joined the global citizen
board Richard Curtis at the back there
who's probably the greatest filmmaker of
our entire time and is also the champion
of the sustainable development goals in
this room are the people you can work
with to drive campaigns that can create
lasting change and on the topic of prime
minister Solberg I want to share with
you one example that shows the power of
citizen action a few years ago with
Stephen Colbert when prime minister when
Solberg was still prime minister we
launched what we called the Twitter
invasion of Norway for girls education
and one night on Stephen Colbert's show
together with Global Citizens we sent so
many tweets to prime minister Solberg
that she called us from from Oslo the
next day and said come to Oslo I'm sick
and tired of seeing all your tweets I'm
in the middle of a local election and I
need you to shut up and um true story
and so we flew to us I'm not joking this
is actually what happened we flew to
Oslo the next day and she said what do
you want in a bit nicer way than that
and um and and two weeks later two
months later beg your pardon she got up
on stage at Global Citizen and committed
200 million dollars for girls education
so that's the power of
[Music]
um
and and I say that I say that because
the next few days
you're about to hear in addition to what
you've already heard you're about to
hear from people who have plans to
create lasting change
Mia Motley the Prime Minister of
Barbados who's with us right now
has been one of the few people who've
championed the issue of fair financing
for the emerging markets and for the
developing world
most of the world's poor don't live in
the poorest economies they live in the
middle income countries so you actually
have to address this as an issue of fair
financing globally
now the thing that we're going to do as
part of the next few days is we're going
to make it easy to take action but it
only starts there it doesn't end there
and what I mean by that is that if you I
don't know if any of you are golfers in
the room if you play golf but we're you
know we're not going to ask you to hit a
hole in one on a par four
we're going to put it right up to the
on on the
thanks t-box you're a legend thank you
Mr Dolan thank you and we're going to
help make it easy to get that Putt in
right and that's just the beginning
that's the example of that campaign with
prime minister Solberg but I want you to
all design campaigns because no one has
a monopoly over good ideas and we need
the ideas of young entrepreneurs from
all around the world who want to design
the next campaigns from a global citizen
who are going to take over my role who
are going to take over mixed role we're
going to take over all of our roles
because it's not about us the mission is
always greater than all of us and that's
what we're fighting for yes yes yes
thank you Hugh Madam president I want to
close this session with you because this
number is pretty staggering to me listen
to this guys wealthy Nations promise to
mobilize 100 billion dollars annually to
help developing countries who are
disproportionately impacted by climate
change but they are 16 billion dollars
short that's a very big gap
what do you think can be done to make
sure they step up and honor their
promise we've talked in the beginning
about trust deficit yes you are right
this is a big gap and it is shameful
that when it have not been able in the
last years to fill that Gap the European
Union has stepped up we have contributed
23 billion to the 100 billion but the 16
billion are still missing
so um we have to Rally my peers that we
come up with the 16 billion this year
because I just said it it's a question
of trust and disappointment and we
cannot disappoint those who are
benefiting from the 100 billion dollars
so you have my word that I will do
everything this year to find you know
those who have not delivered so far and
discuss stuff with them that should we
shame them
what send text messages this is good and
tweets and as much as you can yes
um as much as you can nudge them towards
that and of course it's my job also to
to Rally my peers and to say listen we
have to fill these 16 billion but we
also can do more than that it's not 100
billion only you said it Sabrina that it
is the action that counts that has to be
done now and I think the highly
developed country first of all have to
deliver themselves we are the polluters
so um this was for me the most important
part when I started my mandate to have a
very clear political Vision this is the
European green deal we have cast our
um our goals in a law because I think
only what gets measured gets done so I'm
a big fan of goals that you can then
follow up whether they are being
delivered and we have by now put a price
on carbon not only in industry but we're
just finalizing the law to put a price
on carbon in Road Transport in buildings
in Maritime in aviation because a price
on carbon means very simply if you want
to pollute you have to pay heavily if
you don't want to pay well then innovate
and go into Renewables for example go
into clean Technologies and this is the
way out and it works it works but it's
not only the work at home it's also the
work abroad and there I we have started
a program that we call global gateway
where we invest together with countries
for example from the global South
because if we speak about fighting
climate change we speak about clean
energy we speak about wind we speak
about solar it's green hydrogen and
these resources are in abundance in the
global South so it's in our common
interest that we invest for example in
green hydrogen that is being produced
for example in Africa and used in Africa
but for them also source of income by
having the European Union as
um as somebody who says we are willing
of course to take the green hydrogen
that you want to export or for example
invest in the Great Basin to prevent
deforestation invest in Electric
Mobility
in for example Bangladesh or Costa Rica
so all these are projects We are
following up and I want to say today
because it's not only action over time
but it's action now that as European
Union we have decided together with the
European Investment Bank that we will
mobilize another 18 billion euros to
make sure that there is investment in
critical infrastructure infrastructure
in the global South to fight climate
change together it's action now that
counts all right Madam president
you have had the last word you've had
the last word thank you so much